good morning and welcome to the second
day of Google i/o thank you all who made
it here bright and early and a big warm
hello to folks on the livestream this
session is about Android things the
version of Android that was specifically
designed for IOT products and embedded
devices my name is Vince and I lead
product management for Android things
yesterday you've heard about the
incredible momentum on Android over the
years we've extended Android into many
different types of devices D on phones
and tablets wearables TVs auto and last
year we announced a new version of
Android called Android things
specifically designed for embedded
devices and IOT products I know many of
you have been tracking our regular
developer previews and are already
building great things I love reading
about the projects so awesome for some
of you this is entirely new you're just
getting started and want to know what
Android things can do for you so let me
just get started with some of the
obvious questions what is Android things
for what problems does it solve people
have been making connected devices for
many years what's different now is the
profound revolution in machine learning
powerful models and tools are available
to all developers and there's
ever-increasing demand for smarter
devices
traditionally your only option when
building smarter devices was the gal
delegate some of the serious processing
to the cloud now it's possible to run
much of it on device which is useful if
you need low latency or of your handling
sensitive content and so on and this
growing area is exactly where Android
thing's is targeted it is for devices
that need powerful on device
intelligence when we look around the
devices that populate our homes and
businesses IOT is of course very broad
and diverse so in a sense the product
categories are all familiar we all know
that those II know these it's just the
user expectations that have gone up way
up let me just pick on two use cases at
home we increasingly expect to be able
to talk to our devices and don't know
who we are
another one is smart building devices
such as cameras that can now detect how
many people are in a room and do
something useful with that for example
talk to the HVAC system we know users
want these kinds of devices and we know
we could build them but of course
building these exceeds is actually very
hard especially maintaining them over
time it's actually very expensive to do
this we notice that Google because we've
been shipping these kinds of products
well what's so hard
well first off we're talking about an
entire device so a whole physical
product so responsible for the entire
software stack from the bottom all the
way up to the product experience now of
course the product experience is where
you'd ideally be wanted to spend most of
your time because that's where users are
spending interacting with below the
product experience IOT devices are
currently built using many different
flavors of roll-your-own linux or
android every device is different so
it's hard to expect consistent and
reliable ap is when you go from project
to project you want to reuse what you've
built you want to get support from a
large community at the same time we're
talking about richer experiences with
these devices so obviously you need to
get your app working chances are you
need to get third-party apps and
services working each time you need to
figure out pics of building blocks like
a reliable set of flow from a smart
phone for instance you could do all
yourself
but just feels like extra time and
effort second you need to get down to
the hardware building prototypes with
record processor SOC s have certainly
gotten easier over time people use all
sorts of prototyping tools to get that
done but those don't get you to to
production let alone commercial launch
we're talking about PCB design and
layout involving high speed highly
integrated components SOC vendor
relationships for general support and
bring up component supply chain access
to parts and low volume and so on these
are all very different skill sets you
need to hire for your team again
prototyping solutions get you off the
ground but that
it finally while it's amazing how much
these devices can do on behalf on our
behalf these days the flipside of course
is that they have the keys to our homes
our businesses our back-end systems
clearly there's more and more to gain
from attacking IOT devices
perhaps that's obvious is why it's hard
to provide the security well it turns
out it's incredibly expensive to harden
products out of the gate and to keep
them updated over time it involves a lot
of back-end infrastructure to do this we
notice that Google because we've been
doing this for many products meanwhile
there's immense cost pressure from end
consumers of course and it's hard to
amortize amortized costs without large
volume so those are the issues that our
engineering teams and our business teams
focused on when we build Android things
the thinking was we could take care of
all the challenges that make development
expensive
we provide Android things free of charge
you have less will to worry about our
goal is to reduce the barrier to
building powerful intelligent edge
devices and make it more accessible to
everyone now let's take a look deeper
about building on reliable and
consistent api's Android things is
Android as you'd expect you can write
rely on the same Android API s and
Google services as when you built our
phones familiar tools such as Android
studio and the Android SDK are available
you can build on Google Play services
Google plow platform
firebase including the most recently
announced ml kit that you heard about
yesterday and more of course you're
building hardware so it's also about
component providers SOC vendors and so
on as a device maker usually you'd be
spending a lot of your time interacting
directly to get to a working image with
Android things we've already done the
hard work for you that means you have
access to hardware reference designs
it means the build Support Package comes
from Google and you get a working image
right away you can scale to production
because we've signed agreements with the
SOC vendors to guarantee support Oh
the long-term literally our goal is if
you know how to build an Android app you
can now prototype IOT products and take
them all the way to production you don't
have to be a hardware engineer or
firmware engineer to do this
finally on security our strategy is to
have security features built into the
platform OS hardening is on by default
and you don't have to spend time
figuring it out yourself
what about fixes over time regular
security patches come regular from
Google Google provides all the backend
infrastructure for you to be in control
and you can decide when those go out now
let's go a bit deeper how do all the
pieces that I just talked about fit
together developers often ask me how is
Android things different from Android
how is it different from AOSP
I found that the best way to describe
and your things is that it's a fully
managed solution beyond the AOSP model
at a lowest level we define turnkey
hardware in partnership with the silicon
providers this is in the form of a
system on module architecture I'll talk
about more about that in a bit
but the way the model works though is
that we work closely with the SOC s tool
and code into Google Tree Google is the
one hosting the BSP in fact we have the
system on modules in our test labs
cooked up for continuous integration
moving up to Android and the framework
layers Android things is Android what
we've done is we took Android and we
shrunk it down to around 50 percent of
the footprint of AOSP
I mean they can run with lower compute
and storage requirements security
features are built in meaning they're
done for you and they're on by default
up at the top is the a player we
formalized the boundary so all the
product specific code lives there we
make sure the Google services you wanna
you might want to work with work well
out of the box so your apps can rely on
Google Play services five blade base
cloud platform assistant and more
finally what's pictured on the left side
is the management console if show
cutting across everything from bottom to
top because it's where you control what
exactly goes into your devices it's
where you get access to the bsp that
Google and the SOC vendors are
supporting it's where you create full
product bills with all of your apps and
services included it's where you manage
releases and updates handles over time
as you can see that's why I've described
and your things as a fully managed
solution it gives you a portfolio of
reference hardware to choose from it
gives you Android wear security and key
service is working on top it gives you a
console to configure what exactly goes
into your devices it's all of the
ingredients necessary to prototype and
scale to production on behalf of the
entire Android things team I'm super
excited to share that we are now
generally available version 1.0 is the
first long-term supported release it
came out just two days ago on Monday
fresh off the press many of you have
helped us along the way we've seen more
than a hundred thousand downloads of our
Android things SDK we've received
feedback for more than 10,000 developers
this was all critical to get us to this
point thank you so much now what does
version 1.0 mean to you mean for you
most importantly it means Android thinks
is a stable base for you to build
commercial products in fact we've worked
with a few partners to put and your
things through its paces and vet whether
we could power real shipping products
let me show you a few what you see here
is our first shipping product and it
really put our program to the test this
is a smart speaker by LG and it landed
on shelves last month so story is LG
wanted to build a smart speaker with
high-end audio and go to market quickly
and they felt we'd be a good fit one of
the first things was to determine a good
hardware reference design the system our
module architecture that we talked about
before is in all the shipping products
from your point of view
there's all if this is all done so you
just pick it up it would be a officially
supported platform and you're good to go
well LG was also concerned about ongoing
security fixes and infrastructure to
send over-the-air updates bottom the
bottom line is that these guys want to
be working on amazing audio not worrying
about staffing up a team to do security
and duo s bring up this is a smart
speaker
so there's non-trivial audio processing
for audio casting and a Google assistant
we make sure these work well and a part
of the full solution as well there's
more OMS working on smart speakers and
they'll be coming out in retail soon
soon after partner shows us for a new
product category called smart displays
the idea is a visual Google assistant
there's deep integration with photos
maps video calling YouTube and so on
what you see here are devices from
Lenovo JBL and LG all these guys wanted
to move quickly and that he felt that we
could help them do that at a time we
were already working with SOC vendors or
expanding our portfolio and we're locked
in on a common system on module for all
these products in other words if you
look under the hood all of them are
using the same system on module which is
quite cool again when you work on your
project you can just skip all of that
upfront SOC work and just pick up the
supported design the OEMs were also
concerned about ongoing updates
especially because this is a new product
category they're expecting frequent
updates and during development they
wanted to partition folks into different
groups and AP test the user experience
this is where a console was put to the
test to manage all the builds release
channels and frequent updates now of
course IOT is broad and diverse what's
the most exciting for me is seeing what
everyone has been building based on our
developer previews here are two examples
the product on the right is made by a
company called white flies a wearable
health startup based in Belgium
the hand is holding a sensor that
measures vital signs and a docking
station sends data back to the cloud by
flies let us know that Android things
help turn their docking station into a
secure hub they don't have to worry
about ongoing security fixes and how to
update a device the product on the left
is made by company called marigo based
in Montreal they build a network of
large photo displays running Android
things and are connected to public photo
booths in downtown Montreal sounds
really fun marigo wanted a solution that
could help them move quickly and
actually could help them do that if
you're building a new product powered by
Android things we want to work with you
too we're introduced a special limited
program to partner with the Android
things team for technical guidance and
support if your company is interested in
learning more please let us know at the
link so now that I've shown you some
real products let's switch gears and go
back to how all the pieces fit together
starting from the bottom we talked about
the hardware reference designs we talked
about the system on modules you might be
wondering what do they actually look
like so on the right here is a system or
module Psalm for short this one is based
on an N XP imx7 D all the high speed and
complicated to design atronics are in
the psalm the key components such as the
SOC memory flash Wi-Fi Bluetooth the
base board is what you see on the left
this one shown here is actually one of
our development base boards but you can
imagine as I named product specific base
boards with just the right set of
connectors and plugging the somme on top
the psalm is complicated and quite
costly to design if you were to do it
yourself and we've done the hard work
for you it would also be very expensive
at low volume but the Psalms are what
everyone will be using and that helps
drive up volume for everyone the base
boards are much less expensive to
produce even at lower quantities the
electronics are much lower speed and
Spence what I've shown here is also
referred to as a physical song because
the psalm is on its own board you can
also imagine design and get in so it's
all on one single board and we call it a
virtual Psalm this would allow you to
save on cost at high volume or to better
match XY dimensions for your product
going back to the three smart displays I
showed earlier they all use different
tactics some use physical psalms and
some design it in virtually for each
psalm google proposed the goat the board
Support Package BSP for short in other
words you don't have to interact with
the soc vendors there's a stable layer
of separation with the BSP that makes
your code portable you could imagine
starting development on one Psalm then
swapping over to another at later stages
of production if your design changes
without having to change your code now
part of making the psalm architecture
viable is guaranteed support behind the
scenes we've been working really hard
with the SOC vendors to work out the
collaboration so you don't have to talk
directly to them we are announcing
Psalms that are certified for production
the list includes hardware from nvidia
tech nxp and qualcomm more specifically
psalms on this lists have guaranteed
long-term support and all security
features built in making it possible to
bring prototypes and go all the way to
production hardware and reference
designs for the Psalms will be available
in the coming months so stay tuned
psalm supported for development is
already available now
they include hardware from Raspberry Pi
and NXP development hardware have a
large community of support and are
readily available in retail even at unit
quantities usually for cheap so that
gets everyone started right away the
beauty of the Android thinks model is
that you can easily swap over to Psalms
certify production once you're ready so
everyone has been wondering for the list
of Psalms are
certified for production the ones on the
left how long is the support how much
does it cost
each Saum certified for production is
supported by Google for a minimum of
three years from the time it was first
made available what this means is you
will get regular security patches and
stability fixes from Google for you to
push to your devices you can even set
your devices to auto update and not
worry about it in other words you get to
fully harness the power of the Android
security team of course you can push
your own updates to devices anytime you
want for the entire product lifetime
what about fees there are no charges -
using Android things there are no
license fees for the OS or the
management console the API surface is
stable meaning the length of support is
- provided for each major version this
is why we refer to 1.0 as long term
support we know moving to a new major
version can be disruptive and it may not
make sense for many IOT products so
there's no need to do that let me show
you in a bit more detail each line on
this chart represents a major version of
Android things and of course 2.0 3.0 or
in the future as I said every major
version will have long-term support the
minimum three years we talked about
these major versions do map to
underlying Android desserts and we'll
pick the right points to intersect over
time the important point is when todaro
comes out 1.0 and 2.0 are supported in
parallel the security patches
instability picks fixes come regularly
and that's what each white dot in the
lines represents will also have minor
feature updates on the latest major
version this is so we continue to
address community feedback in a timely
manner so we won't wait for the next
major version to push these out in fact
in the coming months
1.1 will come out with improvements for
you one last note on Psalms obviously
the work we do behind the scenes with
the SOC vendor
is never-ending is an ongoing process
will continue to expand the Somme
portfolio you saw the vendors that
already have something listed officially
and we're deeply engaged with others to
like Rockchip the point is once we put a
psalm up as certified for production
it's a commitment the ones you saw all
support 1.0 and when we eventually add
Todaro
we'll be explicit about which psalms
support it now we've been talking about
the next layer up already since Google
hosts the goofy board Support Package
for every Psalm but what does it
actually look like let's go into that in
a little bit more detail what you see
here is a simplified software stack for
traditional Android mobile device going
from bottom to top the kernel up to the
Hal layers is primarily focused on
enabling hardware support the android
framework provides a rich set of api's
and services for apps and the
applications on top provides user facing
features right now in IOT devices you
can imagine many of the included
components not making sense well you
know embedded devices are usually single
purpose they may not have a screen users
are not installing apps and so on so
first Android things removed most of the
user facing applications and visual
framework components that don't make
sense for example there's no reason for
a text messaging app this removed
unnecessary complexity and reduce the
footprint of the distribution if you
build a device with the display you have
full control there's no system UI to get
in the way now with or without a display
the UI toolkit portions of the framework
remain available to your apps activities
are still the primary component of an
Android app the framework delivers all
input events to the foreground activity
which has focus
next we formalized the boundary between
a system and a product specific code
necessary for the device on a product
specific code is above the line in the a
player everything above or below the
line is provided by Google and ours SOC
partners this way you don't have to
figure out how to put together a working
image Google can sign the full image and
guarantee automatic security updates
over the support time timeframe you
might be wondering how does boundary can
work in practice
well one crucial piece is the Android
things support library I'll touch a
point upon the API surface briefly for
example you may be wondering how to
control Hardware the peripheral IO API
allows apps to interface directly with
low-level peripherals using industry
standard protocols like I Square C and
GPIO userspace drivers allows apps to
inject Hardware events into the android
framework you might be wondering how to
call AP is that usually involve a dialog
or a view to the user these don't make
sense when displays are optional so
we've added ApS to control settings
control device updates and configure
local area connectivity including
Bluetooth and low pen now I'd like to
show you the complete picture we've
already talked about the portfolio of
Psalms you can select from and these
come in at the bottom there's actually
two more building blocks the first is
device configuration and a second is
security let's start with device
configuration is the other crucial piece
along with the Android thing support
library that helps maintain the formal
boundary that we just talked about you
see Tom's can support a wide variety of
hardware so in many cases the OS needs
to know which Hardware is actually
connected in order to properly configure
those interfaces for instance which
audio devices are connected where and
their formats pin muxing
we provide a configuration system so OMS
can divide they're connected hardware in
the console which will customize the
image correspondingly at Bill
time cool let's talk a little bit about
security
well first off they're always hardening
that we do on Android is enabled for
Android things so these are things like
permissions the application sandbox
mandatory access control with SEO Linux
kernel Cisco filtering filtering and so
on
images of signs you don't need to run
any signing infrastructure yourself
Google provides the infrastructure to
build the full image for you this
partitions are signed for security
verified boot which is fully implemented
for Solms certified for production make
sure you're running a valid image at all
times now there's lots of interesting
scenarios that are handled for you and I
always get a kick out of thinking about
them for example what about running an
older image with a vulnerability best
since been fixed robot protection make
sure this doesn't happen
another one is per product keys so
images only run where intended you can
ensure only your product images run on
your devices finally you don't need to
run any update infrastructure Google
takes care of building and serving all
updates the same infrastructure we use
for our own products alright now we're
moving on to the app layer where all of
the product specific code lives
what does building an app on Android
things look like to get started we want
access to the Android thing support
library we just talked about it is built
into the supported devices as a shared
library we're showing code snippets from
two files here at the top is a snippet
of the build Gradle file you declare the
SDK dependency there and I'll get pulled
in the bottom part is a snippet of the
Android manifest file you notice we use
the users library tags so our app can
access the devices shared library below
that is applying the home category to
one of your activities what this does is
that the system will launch this
activity automatically on boot and
relaunch it if the app terminates
this is of course exactly the behavior
you'd expect for embedded devices now
that we have to set up let's do
something useful the example here is
very simple it detects a button press
but it's a good demonstration of how to
interface directly with peripherals
using the peripheral IO API the code
snippet at the top is the Android
manifest file this is where we declare
the required permissions to use
peripheral IO the code snippet below is
the activity there we use the peripheral
IO API to open a connection to a GPIO
pin which is where the button is
connected we configure it a GPIO pin as
an input and attach a callback and
that's pretty much it good to go
a similar workflow is used for all of
the peripheral io interfaces so you can
imagine adding a few lines and you can
light up an LED of course it's not just
about simple stuff there's a wide
variety of peripherals out there your
app can interact with all kinds of
sensors actuators and so on this way
we've expanded our community hub this
week as part of the one auto
announcement the site is Android things
dot with Google comm it brings together
all of the information in one place
samples documents forum also as you
probably guess much of the code we
showed before about driving hardware
peripherals isn't exactly product
specific you can get up and running
quickly with pre-built drivers from our
peripheral driver library these drivers
abstract a low level communication
details associated with many common
Hardware peripherals you can browse the
driver library at the community hub and
we're also now expecting accepting
community contributions as well so let's
all make this better together be sure to
check it out well where do you go from
here well you have full access to the
Android SDK and N and NDK when building
apps you can use Android studio develop
your apps and Kotlin you can leverage
standard developer tools and third-party
libraries
many projects find Google Play services
firebase Google cloud platform etc are
very useful in fact you can create an
end-to-end demo very quickly for
instance if you're collecting sensor
data you can use cloud IOT core to help
you ingest data and do something with it
in the cloud if you're taking photos the
cloud vision API for example can help
you with object detection of course
there's a lot more will have many
samples in a community site for you to
check out let's say a bit more about
Google Play services because we've
created an optimized lighter-weight
version of that for Android things it's
optional so it doesn't take up space if
you don't need it many developers do
find it very useful though you can
literally take a checkbox and add it to
your build from the console you can find
the firebase API is in there which are
which were used in many of our samples
for example the real time database is
very useful when your sync device data
you can also use the new ml kit to
integrate Google's machine learning
technology into your app there's of
course a lot more in Play services fused
location API is nearby for setup Maps
and more the final piece to Android
things is a console for managing what's
running on your devices it's showing
vertically cutting across everything
from bottom to top because that's where
you manage all the builds and releases
for your entire device fleet at every
stage of the product development process
let me explain here's a very simplified
view of the product of element flow
every product goes through the
prototyping phase where you just want to
get something working then a series of
hardware validation manufacturing stages
and finally commercial launch at the
beginning you can pick up one of the
development Psalms because that's the
easiest thing to do and then later swap
to one of the Psalms certified for
production
after you get the hardware you might be
wondering well how do I assemble an
image and push it to the device in the
prototyping phase you probably just want
quick access to a generic image and to
get you going you might only care about
one device so you go to the console and
tell it which song you've chosen and
that's pretty much it you can then flash
the supported image and silo apps to
your device as your product evolves
you'll come back to the console to
customize a lot more for instance you
may want to change the partition sizes
you may want to include Google Play
services because your apps need it you
may want to modify the device
configurations at Build time based on
the peripherals that you're connecting
you may start caring about a lot more
devices for the smart displays and the
small speaker devices that we showed
earlier the OEMs used the console to
split devices into groups so developers
QA early beta testers there are
different groups they all have different
builds and on different update channels
all of this is configured from the
console when you go to production you
obviously need to assemble the sorry
previous slide when you go to production
you obviously need to assemble the
entire factory image that includes your
apps and services you want to update
your app over the lifetime of the device
it's important to have control over
rollout for example rollback if
something goes wrong gradual percentage
to roll out so that you can go slow and
check that things are going well access
to metrics so you can see that things
are going in the right direction all of
this is why the console exists the
underlying back-end infrastructure is
the same as what Google uses for our own
products so just finish explaining how
Android things is a fully managed
solution we have a lot more to show you
at i/o come and see us at our sandbox
dome is the giant bright orange one it's
hard to miss
the entire dome is filled with Android
things demos you can see how real
commercial products evolve from
prototype to production the smart
displays you can see them all there we
talked about devices getting
increasingly smarter we have demo
showing machine learning ingesting
real-time video so it can recognize
emotions faces handwriting and so on by
the way you notice enter things powering
the telling devices outside of the dome
as well they're powering to survey boxes
all around IO for instant feedback
there's a five foot tall robot roaming
around somewhere it's hard to miss that
one and your things in there if you like
to code come to our code labs and get
hands-on we have one showing how to work
with tensorflow cloud IOT how we made
the survey box and more there's eight
more sessions coming up today and
tomorrow that go deeper into specific
topics for example this is the session
at 11:30 today talks about how we built
a smart display product the journey all
the way from prototype to production the
last session we have tomorrow talks
about the console in detail and how to
manage your devices at different stage
of the development process finally let's
all have some fun at i/o join our
scavenger hunt at the length Chico / io
search you might have seen this already
there's very cool machine learning
enhanced flowers that you know that
you'll notice solve the puzzles and you
get a free hardware developer kit with
that let's all go build some hardware if
you know how to build an Android app you
now have a new superpower you can
prototype IOT products and bring them
all the way to production with Android
things you don't have to be a hardware
engineer or firmware engineer to do this
pick up a kit from the scavenger hunt
they'd head on to Android things dot
with Google comm to get started this
concludes our talk my name is Vince
thank you and good luck
[Applause]
[Music]